[Music]  stop right there who are you and how did  you get in here  place is amazing  the air is pristine  underwater  my mother told stories about a place  like this a protected land with people  that never had to leave  never have to change who they were  what reason do you have to rebuild your  secret to the world I am not a woman who  enjoys repeating herself who are you I  had many names my people call me  well my enemies call me no more  [Music]  [Applause]  they came from the water  they had superhuman Strife he's coming  for the surface world  that can't be good  [Music]  now is our time to strike  hold them  black panther wakanda forever  is November 11th get tickets now  [Music]